era tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e dolcissima
posto è più il dato che domenica lo so
che è passato un casino di tempo né
l'ultima volta che ci ho giocato allo
stop non me lo ricordate
l'importante è che ci siamo e che non ci
siamo dimenticato è steve non vi
dimentica mai regalo sapete che affetto
ci ci ci legano i due set vuoi extreme
troviamo il primo a caso così senza un
motivo così ragazzi no questo è un team
questo è un figo come come faccio space
starter flight vai col suo dio ragazzina
figata eddie gomez ai ragazzi è la cosa
che non perché è di mi sta sparando
ovunque
quanti anni ci sono ed i bond e la
madonna si è fatto malissimo
[Musica]
e ti senti devi smetterla di età l'avevo
detto io ho un salvagente
ok vuoi metterti contro il mio
salvagente sbaglia amico mio sbagliate
tutti io e mio salvagente conquisteremo
il mondo ragazzi era cosa no non è mai
capitato di correre un salvagente poi di
sbattere contro un televisore non perché
a me è appena successo
bene una cosa non normale è di con
lanciarazzi intanto va bene nell'attesa
di comunismo a te che cazzo devo fare e
vado avanti che c'era un tizio c'era un
tizio apri la pagina cazzo
siamo nella merda ragazzi perfetto e non
dove non dovevamo entrare nell'acqua
questo è sicuro
siamo fuori ragazzi e poi qualcuno mi
spiega come fa funzionare fuoco del
getto sott'acqua ragazzi aiuto è un buon
sembra quello di bioshock devo prenderla
testate tipo una testata come questa la
stronza gli prende a calci
ok sotto le gambe sotto le gambe di
ragazzi che ha sorriso la vecchia ottana
trovo facciamo questo perché mi ispira
al nome
siamo con ed iva e cos'è comunque il
personaggio di primera navigata come
cazzo ha fatto a non cadere qualcuno me
lo spiega bravo bravo bravo se se se so
che devo riuscire a in the brain a
potente che ho vinto vito i top in
grande ma cazzo una gamba [ __ ] la
gamba mise incastrata taglie the art o
inutile
eccoli è perfetto dobbiamo andare da
qualche punto no perché sono morto
giusto è perfetto non ho vinto perché
sono spezzato a metà ma non importa che
judina macchina da guerra peggio di una
macchina da guerra peggio peggio santa
claus è la pizza come cazzo
sembra un tacchino ri farcito a
capodanno si macchiava è una cagata e
pazienza però da un secolo che non ci
giocavo avevo bisogno di sta cosa era
casa cosa cazzo succede
sì ma cazzo stai calmo
io sparo non tu io sto ca ragazzi sta
cosa madonna che potenza senti ett
dispiace se dica al petto quali marito e
tutti ragazzi sta diventare cos'è sta
cosa cioè io sono sono un killer
cerimoniere deve ragazzi mi stai gasando
troppa donna la pistola più potente nel
web
ragazzi sta cosa mi sta mi sta prendendo
troppo deve uscire qualcun altro perché
ho sete di sangue uscite dove hanno già
sapere che non lo sa che non l'avevo
visto proprio giuro
c'è una casa non me lo sarei mai
aspettato tra l'altro va beh non importa
e si attacca agli alberi giustamento di
foto il fucile da fuori ma che cazzo si
fa ligori che poi dovete spiegarmi che
cazzo ma perché ma perché questa tesi ma
cosa c'è una spagnola e le tette ma
guarda un po e poi è poggiata cazzo ecco
questo questo è il nuovo e un nuovo
amore
[Musica]
forse match devo fare un incontro di
boxe domestica sono io con la sinistra
come ci si muove cosa no no mista
smontati ha smontato
ma cos'è successo schifo ma dai ragazzi
fate mica non aspettate che non ho
capito me mi muovo a perfetto ma buoni
muori stronzo come facciamo a ma come si
muovono lebbra
come ho fatto a spazzarlo via senza
muovere un braccio sa solo lui sau the
glass drake cos'è sto volevo liberarmi
prima che che porta al cannone c'è bavaj
ed enti veloce ma che cazzo di persone
inutile ragazzi sta cosa alla nostra da
un attimo che non capì bravo così a
colpi di pene liberati a colpi di bene
ok ma le settimane che va bene anche
così nba challenge dio mio 9 questa
raffinata
questa è una finché ha fatto sto livello
a merita tutta la mia stima e l'altro ho
fatto un canestro al primo tiro che mi è
venuto a dio se non sono anche io come
ho fatto
ok qua cielo quasi troppo lungo vai a di
ma è una presa per il culo ragazzi era
cosa si guarda il canestro e di non te
lo vorrei dire ma al di là è bravo così
allora ci possiamo rifare non è una cosa
impossibile
guardalo ma porca [ __ ] non è possibile
allora devi bravo ed è che cazzo era
difficile adesso puoi spararla come dio
comanda tanto ho fatto bravo cowes mamma
mia che soddisfazione mi da questo
ragazzo non avete idea paia di così
no no no mica se mi veniva a questo
ragazzo andavo fino in corea nudo non
una cosa
scusi i provini per i lakers sono ancora
aperti e speed racer devo guidare i
ragazzi scuola di guida poi farli genero
praticamente sentire dove arrivano i
suoni perché sono non capisco dove
girare e la cosa è impossibile
credo allora adesso di qua di qua di
nuovo grande numerose non l'ho sentito
però sono ancora vivo sono ancora vivo
dopo due rocce dopo una terza macchina
ragazzi hanno bocciato tre volte in un
secondo
e sono ancora vivo non si sa come
ragazzi sta andando a caso tornando a
caso sono andò a caso tornando a caso se
ragazzo 1 sono andato a culo perché non
capivo più nulla
skyrim skyrim su happy with io vado
avanti di qui ma che cazzo è ragazzi
devo battere braico mamma mia
le mosse più fantastiche che io abbia
mai visto perché così grande perché fu
strada grande come come combattere con
la spada ragazzi tutorial numero 1 come
schivare le frecce fantasti devi
toglierti dalla mia suola sei peggio di
una merda attaccata alla scarpa ai cosa
ho vinto e come portare a termine al
livello se non con una bella testata
jump to victory da quando non sa che
guida una moto
io devo come faccia bravo bravo guida
con la barba come si deve e nonno dove
riuscirà come farlo saltare
vai no no gancia the box sesto gol
[Musica]
e poi le tecniche di guida di nonno ciak
veramente sono le più belle che io abbia
mai visto
e la cosa
voi mi dovete spiegare come fa un uomo a
guidare dalla ruota posteriore c'è sta
cosa ha vinto ha vinto la moto club di
ligue 2 mandare vai o no
eccomi grande l'ho vinto io come faccio
a salire vai e ti spingi spingi con il
ventre ma lì sembra ora puoi fare no no
no non devi tenermi la mano non è il
momento ragazzi ce la posso fare non è
così impossibile a tirarti su 7
io senso meter wings cos'è stacco o dio
è luke corrente sta pedalando il padre
ma dico vai uk a caso mai così io mi
lascio andare perché sono più figo by
luca anche tu c'hai mi vuoi dire che io
mi sono lasciato andare un metro prima
di arrivare al traguardo lo raggiungerò
mai traguardo no no no indietro indietro
stronza
aiutami hope aiuta che cazzo di bambini
in utile aiuto salvato padre salvato
padre salvato padre mia mamma di fare le
sottilette stasera cena cazzo ragazzi la
cosa non mi piace per niente ma uk
adesso mar il tuo brutto stronzo grande
ferma la per tuo padre ferma l'ambito
inutile sia lodato il cielo ma nei
ragazzi facciamo un paio di livelli miei
perché è da 100 per cento possibile
famiglie questo ma mi attizza dalle
norma scritto 100 per cento lo facciano
perché ha fatto lui
ciao ciao anche a te dio
per caso vinto no perché non me ne sono
accorto vinto ho vinto sì grazie a limbo
per fox limbo ma questo è uno spy phone
non è un limbo perché ha scritto limbo
chi ha fatto sto liverpool che pur kabul
c'è anche scritto fa ho capito che c'è
scritto favi gemma dovremmo arrivarci
alla fine poi così come se stesse
facendo la cacca ma tutti sanno che una
tattica far vincere infatti ragazzi
direi concludere qui perché mi stanno
dando a iniziando andare lentissima è
più il sito anche ragazzi se vi è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook che come ogni video ha trovato
nella descrizione senza vorresti
discrete invece diventiamo il prossimo
vinto bene ragazzi
[Musica]